happy new year 2015 to all of my
subscribers all of my viewers everybody
I'm engaged with on the internet and all
the people who might be coming across
this this video what I do every month is
a sort of wrap up of which took place in
the last month and a discussion of what
I've got coming up not only about
YouTube but about my writing my public
speaking other other things that are
going on as well so I'm going to do that
in this video but this will be a bit
more retrospective and a bit more
looking ahead because it's the new year
so I want to talk about the old year and
talk about the year coming up as well
what I want to do before I launch into
2014 is to bring up a few things that
we'll talk about more later on in the
video but I just want to put on your
radar for the moment you might you know
know about them already or they might be
things that you could get excited about
and interested in so we have a new
library series going last year it was
glimpses of existence existentialist
thinkers this year it is understanding
anger and i'll be looking at classic
sources from Greek Greek plays and epics
all the way to Dante's Inferno in
Purgatorio and all sorts of other things
in between as usual we'll be recording
it so if you can't attend the Kingston
library probably the case for most
people right given that it's just one
spot in the world well you can watch the
videos as well I'm going to do more half
hour Hagel videos we're going to try to
get through as much of the phenomenology
as we can I'm going to do some more
existentialism videos and one motivation
for that is because I've got my
existentialist philosophy and literature
class coming out with a plateau open to
the public although it does cost some
because it is a four credit class and it
involves quite a bit of interaction with
with myself as the professor but i'll
talk more about that later on and i'll
do a video about that one as well got
more critical thinking videos coming out
in the critical thinking reasoning and
argument
tation channel critical thinking logic
and argumentation channel and I think
I'm going to be bringing out a few more
new channels this year as as well so
those are the things that we've got
coming up a lot of other things coming
up let's oh one other thing I have to
talk about before I go into 2014 and
this does touch on 2014 but it goes back
a little bit further so as I'm as I was
preparing for this I was thinking to
myself how long have I been here and
doing this and it's three and a half
years now since I made a major career
change that this video work is a
significant part of I left behind a
tenure-track job for you know in which I
was up for early tenure and promotion I
had moved up into a lot of
administrative capacities Iran
university-wide assessment I wrote
portions of the quality enhancement plan
that was presented to the the sax
accreditors so I had a very secure
position but the main reason why there
were two main reasons I moved up here
one was so that I could actually stop
having a long-distance relationship and
have a face-to-face all the year round
relationship with my then-fiance now
wife and my partner in reason I Oh Andy
and that was a really great you know
idea it's turned out quite well for for
both of us because boy long-distance
relationships are just brutal aren't
they and I also decided that well really
we decided that I was being start a
company reason I oh and I was going to
try to do the sorts of things that I'd
always wanted to do more of but didn't
have quite as much time to do as a
normal academic doing a lot more public
speaking shooting more videos public
engagements making philosophy practical
and making it accessible to ordinary
people so it's been three and a half
years things have not moved
as fast as we originally planned but
they never do do they or if they do then
here you have a whole new set of
problems like how am I going to you know
do all this work that I've got piled up
on me so that's something good to keep
in mind you know when we're thinking
about what we're doing in 2015 a lot of
it is centered around this idea of
making philosophy practical and
accessible for for ordinary people for
institutions making philosophy do work
so let's talk about 2014 now let's talk
about December first in december i
finished up the glimpses of existence
library series with the 12th talk on
Gabrielle Marcel and you can see the
video for that as well as all the other
glimpses of existence videos I've got it
in the description for this we finished
up the introduction to the half hour
Hagel series and I got all those those
videos posted so that that's kind of
good you know preface and the
introduction are behind us now now we
can move into the the real meat I
started a new set of videos for a class
that I'm currently teaching called world
views and values from marist college and
each week of that ten week class the
students get anywhere from five to six
lecture videos as a supplementary
resource and I've been after that my
students have first crack at them I've
been letting you viewers have access to
them so far I've only opened up the
first week and I still have one more to
do with that but you can see what they
look like you know first week was on
Plato next week's going to the next week
for them is epictetus there in Descartes
right now so that's a good segue into
talking about classes I actually this
December I've been teaching three
classes online two of them are four week
ethics classes so incredibly intensive
because you're packing 15 weeks worth of
material into four weeks and I do this
entirely online i use my videos both the
class videos and the core concept videos
give this to
a lot of handouts they engage in forums
they do a lot of writing which means i
have to do a lot of reading and grading
which is pretty time-consuming and then
I've got that 10-week world views and
values class for which I am developing
new content every single week because I
want my you know the online classes a
lot of people teach them as if they're
just like a correspondence class read
the text write a few papers I do
something quite different I try to
create a entire environment in which
students are are given all the resources
that they need in order to learn to
succeed that's a lot of work so that's
that's where a lot of December went add
on to that the fact that we had to
travel to the Midwest to see our
families you know spend some time with
my kids and you know December went by
pretty quickly we also unfortunately had
a loss in our little family of our what
my wife calls our 4-legged fam one of
our cats one of the two sisters that we
had she'd been she'd been ill for for a
while without us necessarily realizing
it we thought she was just you know
losing weight and and she eventually
stopped eating and didn't respond to to
you know the various treatments that we
try to do and you know it was very hard
but we had to come to the decision to
put her down eventually is the best best
thing and that's going to be thinking
quite a bit about the pets and our
attachments to them and the nature of
animals and death and what survives
after death so I might do some writing
on that I think I might also kicking
around the idea of writing something
like a so you're stuck in this situation
kind of guide from a philosophical
perspective for people who have to make
big decisions about their pets anyway
that that's one of the things we went
through it was very very hard for both
of us
because we loved her quite a bit and she
was a great cat so what else in 2014 a
lot of things I could I could bring up
and I'm just going to mention a few in
in a more traditional academic setting I
had a few articles and book chapters
that came out one on Jacques Lacan and
ethics that I've been invited to write
for a volume on post modern ethics
another paper was published on Anselm
and God and morality because you know on
the Saint Anselm scholar so I try to
keep doing some work in that field I did
some other writing that hasn't been
published yet that i'll be sending out
and that you know i'm working into book
chapters that sort of thing i did some
conferences presentations and i really
need to get my act together hot setting
that stuff out i also went to european
graduate school where my wife was still
is working on her her PhD located in
sauce face switzerland and when I got
there they gave me the honor of making
me a visiting scholar which allowed me
to attend the class on Schopenhauer with
the the director of the program and also
to get tapped to sit on a dissertation
defense which meant i read it had read
an entire dissertation and give comments
and it was quite an honor so i was happy
about that it's a great school and glad
to be associated with them I've also
been doing a lot more you know
philosophy in public and practical
settings so you know the youtube channel
I started that half-hour Hagel series
like I said we've gotten through the
preface and the introduction which is
pretty big milestone in itself I did a
lot of core concept videos particularly
on Plato but a few other things as well
like WT Ross and Aristotle even someone
Augustine one on Camus I think one on
Sartre I did a few more existentialism
videos and we did that whole glimpses of
existence 12 lecture series that i
recorded at the kingston library as well
i did a lot of public speaking I think I
had something like 30 or 35 different
engagements over the course of this year
and you know with with trying to start a
public speaking career one of the things
that you have to do is either find an
agent or you got to learn a whole new
skill set which is how to how to reach
out to organizations and how to market
and how to do a lot of cold calling so
so I haven't done as much of that as I
could have I really like doing the
research i don't really like doing the
the marketing part so much but you know
you got to do that i think if you're
going to try to be successful i also
would certified as a philosophical
counselor from the the American
Philosophical practitioner Association
and I've been you know working with with
that building the skill set for that
although a lot of that was was really
sort of putting a professional
certification on things that I'd been
doing anyway with people with with
philosophy because I'm attracted to
philosophy that's practical Google
helpouts i started doing Google helpouts
which is a form of video conferencing
and I've helped quite a few people with
that you can see my helpouts if you want
to get involved in a few philosophy
months or weeks or events that are
trying to make philosophy a bit more of
a public concern the first of those that
i did was happiness happens month and i
did some videos for that on the nature
of happiness not quite sure that they
align so much with exactly what the
happiness happiness happiness happens
people wanted to do but you know willing
to work with just about anybody I got
involved with world philosophy day I did
a special dr. Sadler philosophy forum
for that with my friend and colleague me
and Ridhima who
is bringing out this this great platform
called truth score that I've been
helping with you know in the critical
thinking parts and argumentation parts
and then of course in November there was
stoic week and I shot an entire sequence
of videos for that and i participated in
their online course so that was really
quite fun my wife and I actually did the
course together and found it was it was
quite useful for both of us so that was
a it was 2014 let's talk about 2015 and
what we've got coming up specifically in
January and then a bit more about what
we got going on for the year so a lot of
the videos that I'll be putting out in
January are going to be from this world
views and values class that I'm teaching
like I said I've got one more plate 01
to drop on you and then I think I've got
five Epictetus ones I've got six on
booth is I'm going to be shooting
Descartes videos once I get this video
up and running and who else have we got
coming up I mean this is projecting
ahead into februari in March we're going
to be doing Mills on Liberty we're going
to do Wollstonecraft we're going to do
Martin Luther King we're going to do
Karl Marx we're doing jean-jacques
Rousseau's discourse on the origins of
inequality a lot of really cool stuff
coming up with that and so I've got
those videos if you're interested in
following along with the course you can
do that um half hour Hagel videos I
don't know how far we can get in a year
but we're going to see we're gonna put
the pedal to the metal and see how much
of this this dense text we can get
through certainly will get through
consciousness and self-consciousness and
hopefully partway into reason you'll see
just how far we can get with that
existentialism class videos my goal is
to shoot and bring out another 40 or 50
of those over the course of the year I'm
going to be doing a few announcement
videos about different things coming up
this month in particular about the
existentialism class I'm also going to
do a video on
my my philosophical counseling practice
and what that involves and you know see
if because I do it through through skype
as well as face-to-face a lot more
critical thinking videos are going to
fill out that channel and turn it into a
great resource for educators for
professionals for lifelong learners for
students and of course I'll shoot videos
of the talks whenever they let me do
that if not videos i'll be doing
podcasts and so you can you can always
access those what else do we got going
on Oh big thing we've lined up some
office space here in Kingston for the
philosophical counseling practice we're
going to be hopefully getting reason I
own website up and running this month so
I'll have an actual non YouTube now I'm
Facebook Google+ just reason I Oh web
presence it's about time that we
actually did that but you know we're so
busy with with other things that it's
hard to get to that we're lining up more
talks I mean I'm in conferences about
doing talks here it talks there I don't
want to actually announce anything until
till the announcements are made I can
tell you that I've got to tocs coming up
in January here in Kingston one is that
that understanding anger talk and it's
specifically about Greek epic and Greek
tragedy and now I might talk about
comedy a little bit and that's going to
be at the kingston library on the tenth
and then if i remember right through the
17th of the 19th i think it's the 19th
maybe the 18th something like that I've
gotta talk that was originally scheduled
for December but he had to be postponed
due to weather at the unitarian
unitarian universalist association of
the Catskills that is unreal k and his
views on on God on the divine so that's
going to be pretty fun but we've got a
lot of other stuff coming up for
februari March April we're lining things
up now and we're even lining stuff up
for later in the year another thing that
I'm going to be doing a lot more of this
this coming year is more intensive
writing I'm a little bit frustrated by
the fact that I have lots of conference
papers and articles that I've written
and you know have been sitting on for a
while and haven't been sending them out
so it's time for me to really get
organized and starts start setting these
things out to journals because you know
I used to be I used to be pretty
prolific when it came to publication and
I'd like to start doing that again I
also these book projects that I'm
working on a number of different irons
in the fire I don't need to go into too
many of them now because I've already
talked about them in other videos but
the main one that I'll be focusing on
this this month will be the Aristotle
and anger book I've got a few other
Aristotle related projects if you have
anger related projects few other other
projects going on but I'm going to keep
plowing away at those and you can expect
to see some some stuff getting published
this year the books are probably unless
i self-published some things the books
are probably not going to be getting
published this year because of the cycle
for republication takes so long for for
academic and even for for popular
publication but i might self-published
some some helpful guides for people well
we'll see about that that that's a whole
different conversation in any case I've
got a lot of things coming up this this
year I hope that the year is going to be
successful and prosperous way I would be
nice given the economy prosperous for
all of you out there and that you know
if you're interested in philosophy if
you're interested in intellectual
stimulation that you're able to find
whatever resources work well for you
because you know there's a great hunger
a great desire out there for four real
intellectual engagement with ideas and I
think in large part it's not being well
met or there's plenty of resources and
the people over here who are interested
are having a hard time actually can
acting with them so let's end on a good
note let's say this is going to be a
great year for philosophy not
necessarily academic philosophy but for
philosophy in its in its older and more
genuine sense of you know deep thinking
that informs people's lives
relationships plans and you know what it
is that they're they're going to do
think and and love so once again Happy
New Year 2015 to everybody and there's
the wrap-up